bonjour
[Applaudissements]
ça car ça calme hein ça va quoi ça vas y
toi beau plateau ce soir très beau plat
dans le jeu des conneries
ça sonne à l'eau
jean marie
c'est jean marie mai mais les haut
parleurs quand même profil
bas
car je bosse ma poule
chez notre lot de conquête en gironde
ouais je vais passer sous un tunnel
jean-marie
[Musique]
oui c'est ce que je comprends de terre
jean marie on est à combien la
voix
[Musique]
en cash le patron
ouais
tu fais du grésillement quand avec
baffie
téoula t'es où t'es où théo amont
j'arrivais ça va couper il va rentrer
dans une [ __ ]
qu'avait claudia nom jean marie
besset comme on dit claude iront sur mu
et non comme ça roulera aulas il a fait
un geste je voudrais pas
baba allumé la télé tu ne verras tu sais
ce que c'est le direct
ouais non raccroche toi je peux pas moi
non raccroche c'est trop dur
thiam a pourtant atteint ils veulent
parler l'autre qu'on attend
ouais si tu veux poser une question aux
invités jean marie ah ouais on à roger
hanin tu te rappelles leurs jeunes eh
ben il est la figure toi
c'est génial on a fait discret
on n'a
pas sûr on à valérie
alors j'avais une super bonne pour elle
je lui ai demandé si on l'a contacté
pour la ferme
mais trop c'est bien toi
minutes ouais
moi aussi ça les gens marie avec et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous mettez un peu
de bleu